well Hakeem please what are you doing  here Senor  did you lose your ball of yarn you made  angry you don't want to make the cat in  Greece I protect innocent  yeah  is it hurting here or is it me person  boots legend tears of an ancient  treasure hidden for centuries and  guarded by Giants in a castle in the sky  holy Frijole whoever finds this treasure  will be given riches beyond imagination  showing the golden eggs  no please say you have fashioned enough  do not worry I will protect you protect  me who's gonna protect you that is just  a rumor spread by dogs fear me if you  dare  cats that's not what your mama said  my thirst for adventure never be  quenched let's go